[Music]
you've been burglarized I think more
than once twice and you yourself have
confronted the burglar yes chased him up
is that right yeah yeah yeah I mean um
you know one always thinks what one
would do in a situation like that and oh
I know what I would do I would just I
would get I would just climb the
dispersion yeah yeah oh just a panic box
not even a panic room just a box to hide
it well I get very angry you know I work
hard and I live with my girlfriends and
you know heavens forbid I would not be
there when something like this happens
so yeah I went out and confronted them a
couple so what okay tell me what
happened what happened the first time
the first time I had one of those very
cheap garage doors you know like the one
piece kind of tin things and it was 11
o'clock in the morning on a Tuesday and
the guy just ripped it up you know
bent the thing in half and was just
casual as you like walking through my
backyards looking for ways into my house
and you know figuring out how he was
gonna rob me and I saw him and at this
point I only had one weapon in my house
which was a baseball bat next to my bat
yeah and so I thought let's get the bat
see what see what's gonna happen and so
I see what's gonna happen
yeah yeah and so I ran through the house
and I grabbed the bat and I came out I
have French doors in my back F to the
bedroom and I went out just as he was
rounding the side of the house and he
stopped and I looked at them and I said
so we got business mother yeah because
turns out we didn't have business but he
was looking for his book he just turns
around and casual as you like strolled
out I said run that's so amazing so the
next time the next time well then wait
where do you live there's like zombies
coming through the window so then I made
it my business to arm myself you had a
baseball bat that's pretty good but you
know I do you want to take it up a notch
well I just I just accumulated you know
I'd be somewhere to swap me to something
I said oh that would be good and so like
a mace yeah yeah hatchets I have a
samurai sword nice but I also have a
machete but it's kind of old and rust it
doesn't matter the machete doesn't yes
will still get the job Yeah right you
apologize first I'm sorry about to shape
my machetes in right
yeah yeah scoundrel yeah you're the
machete and unfortunately I just have
one weapon in each room so in this
particular room you can be sitting on
the toilet gotta be prepared that's my
biggest fear is to be broken into whilst
in the shower because then you're wet
you're naked it's not yeah so the second
time guy come to the house you've got
the machete yeah it was three o'clock in
the morning and I was learning my lines
and I had my cat on my knee and we
always hear he's the little more
skittish than I am throw the cat let me
tell ya he acts like he's tough he was
out of there he kind of commando doubt
and looked and I I could tell from his
reaction that he really saw something
and he was gone I mean he looked back a
little bit was like sorry bro he got in
his motorcycle
skateboard but yeah and so I had the
machete and I stepped out and there was
this big guy there and I was just
thinking god I wish I had a bat cuz you
can't kind of friendly you know it's not
a friendly maneuver I was thinking if I
turned it sideways I could kind of spank
him with it oh my god you know is it
kind of one more time right but but
thankfully he saw the machete and he
said okay I'm gonna I'm gonna get out of
here I think the word is out do not mess
with your house do not go near your
apartment leave you alone